[Musique]
voici fanny et pierre samuel ds pour les
intimes après cinquante cohabitation ils
se sont mariés
c'était il ya deux ans leur vie viennent
changer c'est qu'ils ont maintenant une
maison et un bébé nous les avons
rencontrés pour leur parler d'argent
j'achète des cascades puis des souliers
non-stop donc je crois que notre couple
ce genre paie pour ça parce que c'est
mes achats y réfléchisse mais l'achat
spontané de la nôtre
l'argent est souvent un sujet témoin
dans les ports de cotonou je comprends
qu'ils appellent tout l'amour que des
fois on ne va pas avoir le même mais
j'ai pas les mêmes passions dépenser
l'argent les mêmes envies de parts et
largeur défaut avec des compromis
cette réalité explique peut-être que
quatre couples sur dix ne discute pas de
leurs finances c'est ce que révèle une
vaste étude menée par la sociologue et
l'aide bello la plupart des gens savent
qu'un mariage sur deux se termine en
divorce par contre si vous demandez aux
gens vous personnellement allez vous
pensez vous aller vous séparer un jour
95% des gens nous disent non
c'est avec beaucoup de bonheur que fanny
en congé de maternité
françois du petit léon une pause
professionnelle donnant pour cette
spécialiste de campagne de levée de
fonds institutionnels qui gagne très
bien sa vie
[Musique]
pierre samuel comptait lui entreprend
une toute nouvelle carrière de
recruteurs de chasseurs de têtes dans le
secteur multimédia
il est présentement le seul soutien de
famille
[Musique]
ça rendrait presque au début de leur
relation fanny et ps se payer les
dépenses communes moitié-moitié bien des
sites excité jo avec toi hein
et on débute c'est moi je faisais
beaucoup mon nerf vague dont conjoint
sauf que je voulais quand même faire
comme si l'on faisait quasiment le même
salaire
il faisait 15 mcdoom à cela ce moment-là
pie ix est un peu juste un peu c'était
été soufflé pour moi il existe plusieurs
modes de partage de revenus et de
dépenses pour deux couples sur dix c'est
moitié-moitié indépendamment des écarts
de revenus comme le faisait au début
fanny et ps c'est souvent le cas des
jeunes et qu'ils vivaient en effet la
moitié des couples utilisent la méthode
du revenu familial c'est à dire la mise
en commun de tous les revenus tant pour
les dépenses du ménage que personnel
pour cet enfant lieu dès le bout du
monde ses toiles à vous demande avec le
temps comme beaucoup de couples ils ont
adapté leur gestion financière à leur
réalité notre décidé d'établir un
système qui calme assez fier découvrir
ou redécouvrir le pari raté là où ils se
seraient déjà romaine où notre venue
ensemble sauf france garde pourcentage
augmente de fort et concret par rapport
à nos salaires on regarde les
pourcentages operator pour nos dépenses
personnelles deux couples sur dix gèrent
comme eu au prorata c'est à dire en
proportion des revenus de chacun
qu'importe les méthodes utilisées
l' enquête conclut que les deux
conjoints devraient investir pour le
futur c'est extrêmement important que
les deux conjoints et les placements à
leur nom parce qu'autrement arrive une
rupture une chicane où ça va pas bien
mais encore une fois ci sont en union
libre et les placements qui sont faits
au nom d'un des conjoints lui appartient
et le double sur dix prévoit une
allocation domestique soit un montant ou
conjoint qui s'occupe de la maison
ce qui est important dans tout ça c'est
d'un impôt juste compter l'argent c'est
de compter aussi le temps c'est le temps
qui est émis par exemple dans la vie
familiale pour prendre soin des enfants
ou d'un parent qui qui est en perte de
tenues qu'ils soient mariés ou non les
couples au québec gère selon l'étude
sensiblement de la même manière les
questions financières
le mariage c'est une célébration de
l'amour alors c'est comme si ça camoufle
un peu toute cette question n'a pas
besoin d'en discuter tout fn avance
puisque une fête de l'amour
principalement laquelle on convie les
amis et tous
mais la moitié des conjoint union libre
croient à tort avoir les mêmes droits en
cas de rupture que ceux qui sont mariés
en cas de séparation le conjoint est
mariée le plus pauvre a droit à une
pension alimentaire
ce n'est pas le cas pour le conjoint de
fait la confusion viendrait de ce que
les lois sociales et fiscales traite de
la même façon tous les couples ça fait
combien de temps que vous êtes un
conjoint une fille ça va faire bientôt
cinq ans jade et yannick rencontre leur
notaire
ils veulent connaître les avantages du
contrat de vie commune en cas de
séparation
est ce que pour vous vous besson c'est
par chacun repart avec ses comptes de
banque ou est-ce qu'au contraire on dit
baye ce qu'on a accumulées depuis qu'on
est ensemble on aimerait mieux que ce
soit partager de façon égale je me suis
sûr le propriétaire de la maison mais
madame pour autant réclamer la moitié
même solo contribuer au paiement de
l'hypothèque en cas de décès le conjoint
de fait ni rythme et les jambes mais on
devine organisèrent un seul à rentrer
dans la tête on n'hésitera jamais assez
là dessus mais aux termes du code civil
du conjoint de fait n'ont pas de droits
cédés étrangers - d'un couple sur dix
vivant en union libre à clarifier sa
situation grâce à ce contrat qui force
les conjoints envisagé la possibilité
d'une séparation
il est plus courant d'aller chez le
notaire pour un testament
quand on fait un testament on dit à
l'autre je vais t'aimer au delà de la
mort alors même je vais prendre soin de
toi même quand je serai plus finalement
quand on fait un contrat de vie commune
ou un contrat de mariage malheureusement
un contrat de séparation
[Musique]
au québec quatre couples sur dix vivant
en union libre
mais les milieux ruraux comme la
gaspésie détiennent des records
plus de la moitié des couples avec
enfants ne sont pas mariés alors qu'à
montréal c'est seulement 2 sur 10 qui ne
le sont pas
au québec on assiste à un renversement
complet du sens du mariage de plus en
plus de couples se marient pour célébrer
leurs 20 ans leurs trente ans de vie
commune
ce qui est particulier c'est que c'est
ça rentre en fait dans le rituel
amoureux et mais ça ne rentre pas ça ne
sonne règle pas les questions juridiques
je peux dire parce que ce qui va être
partagée après vingt ans de vie commune
c'est en fait ce qui était acquis
pendant les années de mariage donc si on
se marie sont ses maris il ya un an mais
ça va être ce qui était acquis pendant
cette année là c'est pour rétroactif si
peu dire
oser parler d'argent quand tout va bien
c'est le souhait de la sociologue
hélène belleau son ouvrage vise à lancer
dialogue
c'est une job de caractère qui paye
caramel pin job de 40 ans qui paye de
zambie les spotters parce que ce canal
internet plus passer le balai le savoir
rapport plus gêné